[Applause]
[Music]
that was Kris Jenner dishing to et about
daughter Khloe Kardashian at Monday's
Met Gala now a Kardashian source
exclusively tells et Khloe is cautiously
giving Tristan Thompson another chance
following allegations that he cheated on
her with multiple women while she was
pregnant like I don't even know how to
describe it besides it's just so the
source says quote Khloe took some time
away from Tristan to really think
everything over Chloe also had some time
away from her family to consider
everything without outside influences
I'm gonna figure it all out I promise
you adding that Coco wants to do what is
best for her newborn daughter true Khloe
is extremely loyal and is giving Tristan
another chance because she thinks her in
Tristan can make it work for true
Khloe is hopeful but has her
reservations there's a million different
emotions that are going on in my brain
according to the source the couple is
trying to reconnect through date nights
quote the future of Khloe and Tristan
isn't a sure thing but Khloe is willing
to do whatever it takes to make it work
but the rest is up to Tristan
[Music]
you